une semaine après la disparition du
journaliste saoudien jamal khashoggi les
enquêteurs turcs peuvent accéder ou
consulat de l'arabie saoudite
le commentateur de renom exilé aux états
unis depuis un an n'a plus été revu
depuis qu il y est entré la semaine
dernière pour obtenir des documents
c'est lui que l'on voit entrer sur cette
image le consulat maintient qu'il est
ressorti rapidement sa fiancée turc
qu'ils attendaient sur le trottoir
elle affirme qu'il n'est jamais
ressortie des enquêteurs turcs ont
depuis affirmé à des proches de jean
marc h dit qu'il croit que journaliste a
été assassiné le consulat avait déjà
ouvert ses portes en fin de semaine à
une équipe de l'agencé de presse reuter
espérant faire taire ces rumeurs
le président de la turquie recep tayyip
erdogan avait intimé à l'arabie saoudite
de prouver avec des images vidéos et
jamal khashoggi avaient bien quitté le
consulat comme le prétend l'arabie
saoudite
boum il guidait les autorités
consulaires ne peuvent pas s'en sortir
en affirmant simplement qu'il est parti
dit il
une foule qui l'on donne la preuve de
plus en plus de voix s'élèvent pour
demander que la lumière soit faite
la grande bretagne la france les états
unis et l'union européenne se disent
unanimement inquiets et réclament des
réponses tout comme les nations unies la
parente disparitions forcées de monsieur
rachel j du consulat du royaume de
l'arabie saoudite à istanbul est une
grave préoccupation dit elle si les
rumeurs de sa mort et les circonstances
extraordinaires qui ont mené se confirme
est ce réellement choquant des experts
des nations unies sur les disparitions
forcées réclament une enquête
indépendante sur des rumeurs
à 59 ans jamal khashoggi s'est taillé la
réputation d'être un franc tireur
un commentateur intègre de la situation
politique en arabie saoudite
tantôt critiquant la famille royale dont
il était proche tantôt saluant les
politiques qu'il juge est bénéfique pour
le pays
mais avec l'arrivée sur le trône du roi
salman et la montée fulgurante du prince
héritier mohammed bin salman jamal
khashoggi ne se sentait plus en sécurité
en arabie saoudite
il ya un an il a donc choisi de quitter
le pays
aujourd'hui résident permanent des états
unis le journaliste a continué d'émettre
ses opinions dans les pages du
washington post se montrant de plus en
plus sévères à l'endroit de mohamed bin
salman entre autres au sujet de la
querelle diplomatique entre le canada et
l'arabie saoudite
sur la question des droits de la
personne le président des états unis
affirme qu'il ne s'est pas entretenu
avec qui que ce soit en arabie saoudite
au sujet du journaliste mais qu'il le
fera je ne sais rien pour l'instant
dit-il je sais ce que tout le monde sait
rien du tout
la disparition de jamal rachid j'y viens
envenimé des rapports déjà tendus entre
la turquie et l'arabie saoudite
les deux ténors du monde sunnite qui se
font concurrence sur le plan politique
et religieux la visite du consul à par
la police turque n'apportera sans doute
pas de réponses à ces questions mais
elle permet de ménager la relation
difficile entre l'arabie saoudite et la
turquie
ici marie-eve bédard a pas de au canada
beyrouth